My friend will come and visit me here in Korea next week.
Mi-na, can you do me a favor?
Since I don't know a lot about Korean culture,...
...I want you to guide us and talk about what makes you proud to be Korean.
Do you think you'll be available to do that?
Absolutely! Let's see, I have to think about it first.
Where should I take him to and what should I be talking about?
What's he interested in?
Good question!
Actually he's a science geek.
He loves playing around with machines.
To give you an idea,...
...maybe it's good to take him to the science fair or something like that...
...since Korea is one of the most technologically advanced countries.
I'm sure he will even love observing people on the subway watching DMB's.
Then he perhaps will enjoy just browsing around at the many different kinds of cell phones in Korea.
You know, Korea exports almost 2/3 of the world's mobile phones.
I guess we could show off the nanotechnology industry too.
Hmm, what are some other attractions we should take him to?
What about shopping malls, department stores and markets?
Many Japanese and Chinese tourists don't miss visiting those places.
I'm pretty sure he will love those crowded places too.